my name is prasad raghavendra
i'm one of the senior scientists at
simon institute uh the other senior
scientist is
vancouver swami in my research advisor
so
one of the my pleasures as a senior
scientist is to
welcome the fantastic group of young
researchers who come to simon's
institute every semester
as part of the programs
and
me
senior scientists will be the point of
contact
for any issues related to fellows
whatever
[Music]
issues related to the feathers b
and
so this semester we are
happy to have uh 16 um
maybe 17 um
great young researchers who
are have come here for the well as
fellows for the two programs here uh
fellows are really kind of the part of
the core of all the programs that are
done at science institute you know that
you must have already seen all the
reading groups are run by them all the
talks all the decisions get made by them
and so it's a great really good uh
opportunity today to see all the fellows
and hear from their exciting research
work uh so
uh today uh we'll have ten minutes talks
from uh all the fellows uh start with uh
uh kiran kumar shiraguru from stanford
okay
hello everyone today i will talk uh
provide a brief overview of our work on
designing efficient universal estimators
for
this task of property estimation
the setup
for this problem
is that
you have some hidden distribution
and you have some limited
samples
from this distribution
with these limited samples you don't
hope to learn the distribution
but in fact you only get to observe a
tiny portion of this distribution
and the task we are interested in is can
we extract some meaningful information
about the whole distribution which also
includes this
unseen part
so for
when i say extract meaningful
information i mean estimate some
property of the distribution
so for many properties
the time and sample complexity for
estimating those properties is pretty
well understood
but all this prior work
focused on designing
property specific estimators so for a
particular property a very fine-tuned
estimator for that property which
achieves optimal and
efficient time complexity was studied
so
what
we study is
given some class of properties
can we design an efficient
sample optimal universal estimator for
those
class of properties okay
so in this talk i will mainly focus on
discrete distributions and i'll assume
that my samples are iid and the class of
properties will be estimating
our so-called symmetric properties that
i'll define in a minute
okay so
let me formally define this question so
you have some hidden discrete
distribution p
defined over a domain d
and you are given some n iid symbols
from this distribution which i denote by
xn
and i'm going to refer to it as a
sequence from here on and the goal is to
estimate some f of p where f is a
function and i'm going to refer to it as
a property of the distribution okay and
as i mentioned earlier we are only
interested in properties called as
symmetric properties these are
properties that are invariant to label
permutations which do not depend on the
label information
so here are two
popular symmetric properties so one is
the support which is the number of
non-zero probability values in a
distribution and also entropy and note
that if you permute the labels the
property value doesn't change
so
[Music]
for these properties and many other
well-known symmetric properties which
have written their
time and sample complexity for
estimating them is already studied well
understood and we have property specific
optimal sample optimal estimators
but the question we are interested in is
can you come up with one estimator that
works
for all these properties simultaneous
properties simultaneously and achieves
optimal sample complexity okay
now
what do i mean by one estimator
so
given a samples
you want to output a distribution p hat
independent of what property you want to
estimate
and the hope that when you output the
property value f of p hat it's close to
the property value of the hidden
distribution so this is what i mean by
universal estimation so you output a
distribution independent of the property
and hope that
when you calculate the property value on
this output and distribution it's close
to the hidden distribution
okay so let me uh switch gears and
define a different maximum likelihood
than what you have traditionally seen
i'll tell you
it's interesting in its own right and
later i'll tell you how it's related to
this
task of symmetric property estimation
okay so let me define this
through an example
consider a domain
d with three symbols
which is
abc
suppose you receive some three id
symbols from this distribution let this
samples be aab which i'm going to refer
to as a sequence
the profile
of a sequence
is just the multi set of frequencies so
in the sample aab
you see that a appears twice and b
appears once so the profile of that
sequence is just 2 comma 1 okay
now
what is the probability of observing
sequence sequence aab
since these samples are iid it's just p
a square pv
and now you can ask what is the
probability of observing profile two
comma one uh it's just uh
consider all the sequences that will
give me two comma one as the profile and
add up their probability values okay
so i have written down
the sequences which will give me the
profile 2 comma 1. for instance you will
note aac also gives me the probability
profile 2 comma 1 so i'll basically add
the probability corresponding to all
these sequences that's my probability of
a profile
okay
now
you have already seen sequence maximum
likelihood
which is basically tries to find a
distribution that maximizes the
likelihood of observing xn the sequence
xn the profile maximum likelihood
uh it's just the distribution that
maximizes the likelihood of observing
the profile fee okay
now what's interesting is that these
distribution chains uh are very
different uh for even simpler examples
for instance if your sequence is a a b
your profile is 2 1 the sequence maximum
likelihood
it's pretty well known that it's just
the empirical distribution it's going to
be two third and one third but the
profile maximum turns out to be half and
half okay
uh even more surprising example is the
second one suppose your sequence is a a
b c then note that the profile is 2 1 1
it's a multi set so i'm repeating 1
twice
2 corresponds to a 1 corresponds to b
and another one corresponds to c the
sequence maximum likelihood is again the
empirical
it's half one fourth one fourth but it
turns out that the profile maximum
likelihood is a uniform distribution or
five domain elements
so
note that you only observe three symbols
but it's assigning nonzero probability
mass on these unseen symbols
so it's a pretty
exciting
that it starts predicting that there
exists these unseen symbols even with
such fewer samples
okay
so
why is this
maximum likelihood even interesting
the first thing to note here is that
for estimating symmetric properties
which are invariant to label
permutations
profile is a sufficient statistic
profile doesn't store label information
it just keeps track of frequencies that
is sufficient for estimating this class
of symmetric properties
in 2016
there was this
amazing work by achara at all where they
showed that this pml is actually sample
optimal for estimating this class of
symmetric properties okay so you defined
a new maximum likelihood
it ends up being optimal for this class
of symmetric properties
in fact what they show is that their
analysis even works for some approximate
notion of this maximum likelihood which
i'm not going to define here
uh the the question we were interested
in is all this was some statistical
guarantee of this maximum likelihood but
we didn't know how to compute these
distributions
so the question we were interested in is
can we compute these
but the challenge here is that the
probability of a profile corresponds to
permanent of sum matrix
and computing a maximum likelihood
corresponds to maximizing the permanent
of a matrix where these entries of this
matrix depend on the distribution and
the profile okay so
if you if people have heard about
permanence they are difficult to deal
with in general and
on top of that you want to solve a
maximization problem so it's a
difficulty at two levels
in our work
we sort of provide the first efficient
algorithm to compute these approximate
pml distributions
um ours was the first algorithm which
gave some probable guarantees
uh
prior to our work since its introduction
in 2004
four there have been many heuristic
algorithms but
but none of them had any provable
guarantees
in in my other line of work we also
provide some
tight statistical analysis of this pml
um all this is in joint work with uh
neema moses yanjun and aaron
i think anjun is one of the audience
here
yeah
so
what's the takeaway one take away from
this talk is that if you want to
estimate some class of properties
here is a general recipe to do it so
identify the sufficient statistic for
estimating that class
compute the maximum likelihood or that
sufficient statistic and just output the
property value of this computed maximum
likelihood
in the case of uh in the in the case of
symmetric properties
discrete distributions iid sampling we
are sure we are able to show that it's a
statistically optimal but
i believe that this this holds in much
more generality for other class of
properties in many other settings okay
this is the general recipe for doing the
estimation
now uh so apart from this line of work
i also spent a good chunk of time trying
to
apply
uh algorithms for some interdisciplinary
research uh
i hope
here are some of the projects uh where
in one of the projects uh we have tried
to model
uh how
and trail networks uh
formations happen uh in particular in
fields it's observed that ants
find some notion of a shortage path
in order to minimize the probability of
getting lost uh
we did the modeling to explain why this
this particular
observation is true in the field
observations
i also worked on assortment planning for
two-sided matching markets and some
co-ed modeling projects where i was
interacting
a group of team from stanford was
interacting with los angeles school
district
trying to
understand what should be different
strategies in reopening schools
and i have worked on some other projects
so if you want to know more about any of
these you can come and talk to me later
thank you
okay
just a second
okay
hello
um can you see my slides
yes
okay great
okay so next speaker is uh ellen
wiederchik uh
she's a miller fellow and she's here
okay thank you um so i am going to give
a short talk about some of my research
related to machine learning and
mechanism design
so um